I'm going to talk about
William Carlos Williams today.
It may be that I end up carrying a little
bit of Williams over to next time too.
Um, uh, uh, Marianne Moore, his friend,
a contemporary and a really close,
um,
uh, close, uh, uh,
collaborator in a sense in the,
uh, uh, New York, uh, uh, scene of,
of modernism in the, uh, teens
twenties, thirties, forties, uh,
and on into the 50s. This is, uh,
this is the man, uh, as a young man,
uh, uh, William Carlos Williams.
If you open your, um, uh,
anthologies to page two
84 in the long head,
note that, um, and useful
headnote that Jihad Ramezani, uh,
provides you, uh, there's
this quotation from a letter,
uh,
in the middle of two 84 that
Williams wrote to Harriet Monroe,
uh, the editor of poetry who, uh,
13 years later Hart crane would a right
to in defense of his palm at Melville's
tomb. Uh, and William says
in this letter to Monroe,
most current versus dead from
the point of view of art,
it's dead. It's lifeless. Uh,
and what Williams cares about
is something he calls life.
Uh,
now life is above all
things else at any moment,
subversive of life as it
was the moment before.
And I think that's how we know it in
William's life is whatever is subverting
whatever was a, a moment, uh,
before and subversive as is probably
an important and suggestive word there.
Uh, uh, subversive of life
as it was the moment before,
always knew irregular.
He wants what is new,
uh, and what is new is going to be what
is your regular and what is irregular, uh,
has in some sense, uh, uh,
subverted what was in place before,
uh,
he continues verse to be alive,
to have,
you know, what pound I think
would've called the impulse, uh,
for verse to be alive.
Uh,
it must have infused into it
something of the same order.
It has to have life in it,
uh,
or what he calls some
tincture of disestablishment,
something in the nature of an impalpable
revolution in ethereal reversal.
Let me say, I am speaking
of modern verse, uh,
like, uh, uh, certain of
our other poets. Um, uh,
Williams is his self consciously
modern. Uh, he's defining, um,
what modern means.
Uh,
and he's defining it as a quality
of a experience that he calls life,
uh, that has the quality
of disrupting, uh,
whatever, uh, was, uh,
in existence before. Uh,
and this is a quality, uh, in energy, uh,
that he wants to have
in his poetry itself.
Uh, this is a Williams
a little bit older, uh,
Williams in 1924,
uh,
1924, uh, when he has, uh,
established himself through the poems
in a volume called springing all,
uh, as one of the, uh, major, uh,
modern poets in America,
uh,
he is the author of a poem.
Have you ever seen it
called the red wheelbarrow?
Uh, and, uh, that might be
a good place to begin. Uh,
that's on to 94 to 95. Uh,
of course I'm joking. Uh,
probably,
um,
that's the one poem every body in this
class has read before they came to this
class. Uh, it is, uh, you know,
better known than the Negro
speaks of rivers or stopping
by woods on a snowy eve.
Um, uh, even, uh, it is,
uh, also distinguished,
I think as, uh, being the
second shortest modern poem. Uh,
after in a station of the metro,
a poem that it's related to
in certain ways. In fact, uh,
you know, a link between Williamson
pound is, is important. It's relevant.
A pound was a friend and
rival for Williams, uh,
throughout his career. Um, uh,
Williams is sometimes seen, uh,
in his, uh, early stages, uh,
as a, as a kind of images, uh, or, uh,
at any rate as a poet
influenced by, uh, the image,
just a aesthetic image.
Ism is of course,
a visual metaphor.
Uh,
and Williams is above all a visual poet,
a poet of the eye.
Uh,
so much depends upon a red wheelbarrow
glazed with rain water, uh,
and, uh, uh, beside
the white chickens. Uh,
well,
uh,
I think you have to see that poem to
start to really be able to read it, uh,
to, uh, it's, it's, uh, uh,
I think probably does involve some subtle,
uh,
vocal and auditory experience. But, uh,
it's first of all a poem that
meets you and challenges you, uh,
through the eye,
uh,
as a visual object in
some sense on the page.
Uh, the, the kind of seeing
that Williams's poems call for,
um, is, uh,
we can think of as a way of
reading that has, uh, uh, deaf.
His poems themselves
demand. Uh, in other words,
there's a kind of link between how he
sees the world and the way in which he
asks us to read him. Uh, his poems model,
a kind of seeing,
uh,
unlike in a station of the Metro,
the red wheelbarrow, or let me call
it instead, so much depends, uh,
is a poem a without a title. Uh,
this title, the Red Wheelbarrow was,
uh,
like the title.
This is just to say in the
poem that follows the almost
equally famous pump. Uh,
these are titles, a Williams,
uh, added, uh, later to his work,
uh, in spring and all that volume, uh,
first edition 1923,
uh,
the poem appears simply as a,
a text on the page.
That's important. Uh, it's, part of,
it's as important as the title
is for infestation of a metro.
Uh, simply presenting the poem on
the page to us as Williams does.
Doing it without a title
a Williams asks us to,
in some sense, read and encounter
this poem without a frame,
without some kind of pre established
a boundary or explanatory,
a introduction or entry. That choice, uh,
increases the immediacy of our experience.
It's as if a Williams, we're asking you
to kind of press up close to the poem,
uh, uh, face it, uh, uh,
just as he is facing the thing
he is writing about, uh, or,
uh, asks us to face, uh, well,
not the, the thing that he's writing
about so much as his act of writing,
in seeing his act of writing
as it embodies a way of seeing,
uh, it has, uh, the poem has
a suggestion, um, that, um,
uh,
it requires as a poem the same kind of
calm intensity of concentration that the
poets observation of the
wheelbarrow exemplifies.
Uh, so again, uh, you know,
the, I think the, the,
the kind of seeing that the poem does,
uh,
models away of reading.
Well,
uh, what is that way of, uh, reading, uh,
what is the, um, uh,
how does the poem embody
in its construction,
which it calls attention to? How does
it embody in its construction, uh,
emotive perception, a
way of, of seeing, uh,
how has William's organized, uh, this, uh,
language on the page,
uh, by what principles,
uh, looking at it? Well, uh,
as I suggested before,
it's not a poem.
I think that we begin by hearing a,
and we have to start reading it and seeing
it before we can even think about how
to really speak it properly.
Uh,
it is not a metrical poem.
This is not,
I am Beck pentameter.
It is a,
a free verse poem, um, in the, uh,
in the prologue to Cora
in hell. Um, which is,
uh,
the pros I asked you to read for
today at the back of the book.
Um, there's, there's a number of
sentences and ideas that
are, uh, important. Uh,
I'll call attention to
just a few on nine 58,
uh, William says, nothing
is good. Save the new.
Yeah.
If a thing, ha, if a thing have novelty,
it stands intrinsically beside every
other work of artistic excellence. Uh,
and if it doesn't, no loveliness or
heroic proportion or grand manner,
we'll save it. Uh, and he, uh, uh,
identifies here as elsewhere.
Uh,
this property of novelty with, uh, uh,
kind of verse that, uh, his shoes, um, uh,
rhyme and meter, uh, a whole
host of, uh, existing, uh,
poetic conventions. Uh, again,
in the headnote two, um,
uh, the William Selection, uh,
there's a, a quotation, uh, from, um,
uh, Williams on the subject of, of,
um, uh, meter, uh, on to 85, uh, from, uh,
his pro statement, the poem as a field
of action. Uh, he says, I propose,
I propose sweeping changes from top
to bottom of the poetic structure.
I say we are with a,
I am back pentameter as
presently conceived, uh,
through with the measured quite train,
the stayed concatenation of
sounds and the usual stanza,
the Sonnet so much for the Silken tent,
uh,
Hart crane, a Wallace Stevens, et Cetera,
uh, pound, uh, uh, excuse
me. Williams is a, uh,
insisting that a modern verse,
the kind of verse he
describes a has to be, uh, uh,
has to break with these models
and has to, uh, proceed, uh,
by a kind of, um, uh,
by patterns that it itself invents.
A free verse is a, in
that sense, the, um, uh,
uh, Williams is chosen
medium, uh, free verse, uh,
meaning, uh, a poem not pattern
by metrical scheme or rhyme, uh,
or, uh, indeed, uh, some other, uh,
in the sense preexisting
principle or pattern. Uh,
nonetheless,
uh,
free verse does always have
some kind of operative pattern,
uh, sometimes, uh, very strict
and structuring ones. Uh,
and this short poem is a good
example. Uh, in fact, uh,
as you examine it,
you see a series of four stanzas,
right?
A four to line groups since, uh,
Williams might not like the word stands,
uh, uh, uh, four to line
groups. And, and, uh,
the pattern is long, short,
um, three or four syllables,
um, uh, followed by two.
Uh, and, uh, this, this, uh,
this is itself almost, uh,
like a, a, a metrical or,
uh, or a rhyme scheme.
In fact, you could say this, this poem,
this is more strict than a Sonnet,
uh, that it's more limited in the
range of choices that it allows.
Uh, it isn't, however,
presented to us as sonnets are.
As an instance of a, um, uh,
received verse form, uh, that is, uh,
at least in its general
pattern in variant, uh, and,
um, um, uh,
again a preexisting instead,
the poem presents itself as a
kind of ad hoc arrangement, uh,
as a,
as a kind of a structure that the
poet has chosen to work within,
uh, reflecting the
contingencies of this moment.
Uh, the occasion, uh, the poems purpose,
uh, the, the poem, the poem shape,
and this was one reason it's, it's
hard to speak. It's hard to hear, uh,
organizes Williams his speech,
uh,
in a manner that disregards or disrupts,
normal, uh, familiar, uh, syntax. Uh,
it does. So a specifically through
in jam by carrying one line,
a one line over to the next,
uh,
Williams is in jam
[inaudible] have here as, uh,
throughout his poetry.
Uh,
the effect of breaking
up language, uh, uh,
breaking it up, a, forcing us to
in fact, slow down our reading,
uh,
to stop taking languages
sense making for granted.
And in a sense to get into the poem,
uh,
the white space in w a Williams palm is a,
is you can think of it as
a space for thought. A,
a space where we are
invited, uh, allowed, uh,
required to think about choices,
um,
to ask ourselves about what a possible,
uh,
connections can be made at a given moment.
In this poem,
uh,
William specifically breaks words
up into their component parts,
a wheel barrow,
rain,
water without hyphens, uh, as if,
as if what he was looking
at a red wheelbarrow, uh,
consisted of those three terms,
redness, uh, the wheel, the Barrow.
Uh, these are, it's a
component elements, uh,
he points out in effect
in this device. Um, how,
um,
in this case,
two nouns that are made of compounds
that are really compounds represent
things that are compounds,
uh,
things that are made up of
other things that have parts,
uh,
as he established this as this pattern.
So much depends upon a red wheel
barrow glazed with rain water.
You want to carry it forward,
don't you?
Now that we've learned what he's doing
into the next stanza beside the white
chickens,
as if a white chickens were the same,
uh,
kind of compound as rainwater
and red wheelbarrow,
uh, but they're not quite, uh, and, uh,
Williams is in a way teasing us.
Uh,
white chickens aren't made up of whiteness
and chicken this in the same way that,
uh, uh, a wheelbarrow is made up
of a wheel and a bear out. Uh,
he's doing something a
little different here. Uh,
no sooner has he in effect
established, uh, a certain, uh,
pattern of cognition. Uh, a, uh, you know,
uh, um, uh, showed us how
to read his and jam minutes,
then he breaks that pattern. Uh,
he, uh, revises how it works.
Uh, it's just been put in place and now
it's changed and in fact, it's over.
It's done. The poem is done. Um, if the,
uh,
first lines of the poem
and the first stanza is,
are in a sense made to interrupt and
disrupt and thereby freshen our habits of
seeing,
uh,
to make us see these
things in some new way.
This last stanza does away with the
habit of seeing that the poem itself has
just constructed a,
just introduced us to a Williams prevents
us from settling into a convention of
perception.
Uh,
even in a poem that is as
small and as brief as this one,
uh,
there's,
there's really only enough time in the
poems essentially introduction and three
parts following to, uh,
establish a pattern and break it.
Uh,
what this brief moment of heightened
perception allows us to see,
to experience,
uh,
it's something small and large.
Uh,
what is it that depends
on the red wheelbarrow?
Williams only says so much.
Uh,
so much.
the idea is I think the beautiful one
that the world when it's glazed with rain
water,
a kind of aesthetic effect and aesthetic
effect that implies a light that does
the glazing,
that somewhere behind our shoulders and
the poets as he looks at these objects,
that that light, which comes after
rain and is a product of change,
uh,
of the energy of the world is it
transforms this light suddenly,
uh,
allows this world to be seen.
Invisible detail,
uh,
apprehensible in its component parts.
And,
uh,
the ordinary gestalt of
perception is interrupted,
uh,
fresh and in reoriented we see something,
something ordinary,
newly, uh, and freshly.
It stands out, uh, in
what we see in miniature,
in the limited space of the
moment or of the poem is,
uh, world. Uh,
well what we see is the
elements out of which, uh, uh,
the world is made elements ordinarily
held in a kind of complex mutual
dependency,
uh,
a kind of complex of relations that
we simply take for granted, uh,
in the words that we use in the,
uh, a way that we see things.
Uh,
just as we put together,
we'll and Barrow and rain and
water without thinking about it.
Uh,
what the red wheelbarrow holes then,
and what in that sense
it depends on, it, uh,
is something pretty heavy.
Uh, and that is, uh,
the sense of a whole world. We're,
we're, we're better, uh, the,
the sense of the world in its wholeness,
uh,
which is something
affirmed, uh, in this, uh,
attractively modest,
momentary poetic perception
so much for the red wheelbarrow
springing off.
Uh,
and there's that idea again in the
title a spring as a season of newness,
uh, for, for, uh,
William's beginning his career spring,
uh,
registering his own beginnings,
registering modernness,
uh,
a vision of the world in its newness.
Well, uh, springing all, uh, isn't a,
is a beautiful book.
And one I wish I could show you,
but the last time I saw it at Beinecke
disappeared and no one has seen it.
And a couple of years, uh, they
have a lot of paper over there.
I guess it's easy to lose
things. Maybe it's, maybe it's
a available. We'll, we'll,
we'll look and see. A, it's a,
it's a beautiful plane book,
a Robin's egg blue,
uh, for spring, I suppose. Uh, it seems,
uh, uh, it's, it's, it's
not, it's not large,
small. Uh, it almost has no ornament.
Uh, in, in all of this, it
seems to exemplify the, uh,
American virtues of a plainness
and a directness and a simplicity,
again, a long way from Hart Crane. Uh,
and the book is, is really, uh, so
American that it was published in Dijon.
Uh, Williams, uh,
is a polemically American poet,
even more than crane in certain ways,
a more than frost even. Uh, and yet, uh,
Williams has,
has a very important and
vital relationship to European
modernism and a French,
uh, modernism in particular [inaudible]
and even more particularly to French
painting.
Uh,
and to understand how Williams is
writing what he's trying to get at.
It's helpful to remember
what he was looking at. Uh,
here. Here's a Brock. Uh, I,
uh, George Brock, a 1908, uh,
it's, you know, on the way to cubism, uh,
and I think sort of helpfully
on the way to cubism because it,
it looks back to a real list,
uh, tradition, uh, with, uh,
it's, uh, in a sense conventional, uh,
Perspec tival space that's yet
being broken up into planes,
uh, that, uh, allow us to, uh, register,
uh, the, uh, uh, painting as a
painting. And that force us to, uh,
really, uh, and, uh, I
suppose, uh, even more, uh,
striking a is, is this,
uh, uh, one of many great,
uh, late, uh, Suzanne paintings
of a limo, Sam Victoire where,
uh, here, uh, again, uh,
you know, um, the, uh,
Perspec tival space of the, uh, uh, uh,
painting as being a, turned
into almost a kind of, um, uh,
abstract field, uh, of,
um, uh, color patterns.
Uh, again, uh,
these are painters interested
in foregrounding their
action of seeing through
the ways in which they
foreground self-consciously, uh,
the materiality of the medium
in which they are working.
Um, the aim in, in, in post
impressionist painting,
and then in, in cubism. Really is to
again, break up that gestalt of, of,
uh, perception, uh, that,
um, uh, Williams is, is,
uh, uh, also opposing himself to, uh,
to break it up and grasp in
some sense the dynamism, uh,
in, uh, the world, uh, before us, uh,
precisely through acts of seeing,
uh,
that call attention to themselves into
the way in which that seeing is rendered.
Um, if you, uh, uh, have,
have read the prologue to Cora and
hell, which is, uh, starts on nine 58,
um, you know, that, um, uh, or excuse me,
nine 54, William's begins with a, uh,
anecdote about Marcel Duchamp,
um,
part of the New York art world
that, uh, uh, Williams, um, um,
also participated in
through his friend, the, uh,
a dealer and tastemaker
Walter Errands Berg. Uh, uh,
once, when I was taking lunch
with Walter Errands Berg,
I asked him if he could state what the
more modern painters were about. Uh,
and then he gives, uh, several, uh,
as examples including a Duchamp,
uh,
all of whom were then in
New York. Uh, and, uh,
Erin's Berg replied by saying that the
only way a man different from every other
creature was in his ability
to improvise novelty.
And since the pictorial
artist was under discussion,
anything in paint that is truly new,
truly a fresh creation is good art.
Thus, according to Duchamp, uh, who
was Erin's burgs champion at the time,
a stained glass window that had fallen
out and lay more or less together on the
ground was a far greater interest than
the thing conventionally composed in
city. You, uh, which is,
uh, uh, interesting, um,
uh, uh, model for, um, what, um, um,
Williams himself might be seen as
doing in poetry. That sound sentence.
He's taking the stained glass window and,
and you know,
seeing it laid out on the floor,
maybe broken on the floor. Um,
Duchamp, uh, uh,
painted this famous work,
a nude descending a staircase,
uh, and, uh, it, uh, is,
is clearly all about,
uh, here rendering, uh,
in a pictorial form,
the kind of a multi
frame, a vision, right?
That, uh, photography motion
pictures allow us, uh, to see, uh,
to, uh, again here, you know,
grasp in representation, uh,
some sense of the movement
and, uh, energy, uh,
that compose a, the, a world that, um, uh,
we see before us. Uh, the other,
uh, dimension of, of, uh, uh, the Duchamp.
A anecdote that that's nice, uh, uh, in,
in Williams is telling us that a
well, a stained glass window that, uh,
and it's falling out as something
you come upon or, or, or find a,
and Duchamp is of course,
uh, most famous for his, uh,
let me turn to the next image. Uh,
his ready mades this,
a facsimile of the are,
that is another version of, uh, uh,
his most famous ready made a fountain.
Um,
a urinal, uh, which we, uh, uh, uh,
signed with the pseudonym,
uh, are moot. Uh,
1917 and, uh, uh, presented, uh,
as a work of art. The,
um, uh, our gallery, uh,
has, um, um, this work. Uh,
this too is a, is it, as it were, a
facsimile of the original now loss,
uh, uh, a snow shovel, uh, in
other already made, uh, this one,
um, uh, with the, with the, uh,
excellent title in advance
of the broken arm, uh,
uh, Duchamp, uh, takes post
impressionism, uh, to New York,
uh, in the form of data,
uh, a, uh, uh, movement, uh,
with its importance for
Williams to including, uh, uh,
I think, um, duchamp's
mischievousness, uh, in his, uh,
willingness to, uh, provoke,
be subversive to take, uh,
Williams's word, uh, and to play with
expectations about what constitutes,
uh, art, uh,
as Williams in certain ways we'd play
with our expectations about what could
constitute a poem, a or
poetic statement in, um,
New York, uh, and elsewhere, uh,
Williams is in contact
with a whole range of, um,
uh, modernist, uh, American
artists, uh, influenced by the, uh,
European art I've just been
talking about. Um, uh, but also,
uh, working in a distinctively
American, uh, mode.
This is, uh, a, a work by
a shark, Charles de Muth.
Uh, 1921. I'm sorry, I'm behind on
producing my image lists, but I'll,
I'll get this for you. Uh,
and in here is, uh, another,
um, and again, uh, here, uh,
in urban scene, uh, that is, um, uh,
a realist in it's a
mode of representation.
And yet the, uh, uh, for
grounding of, um, the, uh,
uh,
lines created by the different
shapes of the buildings,
uh,
call attention to this as a
indeed a kind of constructed,
uh, image, uh, that is,
seems to be, you know,
moving out of the, um, uh,
realm of realist representation
to something, uh,
more a symbolic and
certainly, um, uh, avowedly,
um, uh, created, uh, by, uh, the artist,
uh, uh, Damuth, uh,
goes further in the same direction
in a what is probably his,
his best known work. Uh, this is, uh,
called the great figure number five.
Uh, if, um, uh, Williams was busy, uh,
looking at these artists
I've just been talking about,
they also were looking at
him, uh, and, and, uh, uh,
do a painting is a, a
attribute to Williams, uh,
and a, a little homage. Also,
I think a little joke about
a Williams is a own poem,
uh, also from springing off, uh,
that we know as the great
figure on two 91. Uh,
this is, um, well I'll,
I'll read this, uh, again,
uh, rain and light, uh,
among the rain and lights.
I saw the figure five in gold on a
red fire truck moving with weight and
urgency,
tense unheeded to Gong clangs,
siren howls and wheels
rumbling through the dark city.
Uh, and, uh, this is, you know, uh,
a rendering of that, uh, uh,
that moment that that draws out the,
I'm a way in which the
poem fines and makes, uh,
an exalted symbol, uh, from
this ordinary perception. Uh,
it's got bill up top and WCW
down in the bottom and Carlos,
uh, underneath the five,
uh, uh, as part of this, uh,
friendly, uh, tribute, uh, the pumps.
Interesting to look at next
to, uh, the red wheelbarrow.
Here's something else that's red,
right? Uh, and, uh, again, um,
uh, the poem is concerned
with a, a moment of,
of perception. Uh, here, uh,
the poem really tries to render the
process by which perception takes place
where, or rather the kind
of context in which it does,
which the red wheelbarrow doesn't. Red
wheelbarrow really kind of takes, this,
takes something seen. Uh, I'm
a fragmented out of, uh, uh,
a continuum of, of perception
that we can feel implied, uh,
but, uh, isn't made explicit
in the poem. Uh, the, um,
uh, in this case, uh, the, uh, uh,
we were given the kind of context,
uh, out of which a detail,
uh, something that arbitrary
contingent, ordinary, uh,
springs out, uh, springs out
of the rush of things, uh, and,
and, uh, uh,
catches the eye and the imagination
and the intention of the poet,
uh,
in a station of the metro.
This is a poem about metropolitan
urban perception. Uh,
so as this poem, uh, here, instead of a,
a present moment that's,
uh, briefly suspended, uh,
as in pound's poem or as
in, uh, so much depends. Uh,
this poem is, is just as
much about memory, uh, uh,
in the, in the, the rush
of, of ongoing experience,
of a kind of ongoing
temporality of, uh, uh,
figured here by the fire truck moving.
And there's that part of Sippeel,
uh,
a word moving kind of ongoing action.
Uh,
in the midst of this, the,
uh, something, uh, um, uh,
catches the poet's attention.
Uh, he acts, uh, uh,
as a perceiver. He says, I saw
in that action, uh, expressed in,
in a verb, in the past tense, uh,
intervenes in and, and,
uh, uh, you know, cuts, uh,
into this blurry,
uh,
perceptual part of Sippeel flow of things.
Uh,
that is the firetruck, a rushing
by. Uh, it fixes on a figure,
in this case, a number,
uh, and, uh, carries that,
uh, away and out of the, uh, experience,
uh, that, uh, that five
on the firetruck, uh,
it's something utterly ordinary.
Uh,
like a wheel barrel or a shovel,
snow shovel.
Uh, it's a kind of found
object, uh, and yet, uh,
here for, um, Williams, uh,
he makes something of it, uh, or, uh, uh,
plays with the act of making
something with it. It is, uh, uh,
something he calls with some joking,
some seriousness,
the great figure, a
great figure, a symbol,
but a symbol of what, uh,
of what exactly, uh, well,
um, perhaps, uh, a symbol of, uh,
the very capacity of the ordinary
to arrest our attention and become
significant, uh, become
objects of perception. Uh,
perhaps a symbol of the
five senses themselves.
What do you think, uh,
that seems possible to,
uh, the five senses, uh, who's powers, uh,
uh,
are behind for Williams,
the way we create figurative language,
uh,
the way we create figures and poems and
discover symbols and discover meaning in
the world around us.
Uh,
okay.
Now life is above all
things else at any moment.
Subversive of life as it
was the moment before,
always knew irregular.
Uh,
the poem that place just after
this anthology is, is, uh,
one of William's this greatest,
uh, and uh, uh, it too,
as it appears in the volume
springing all has no title. Uh,
but it's given a title here, the
title of the volume itself, uh, but,
uh, was known rather, uh,
for a long time simply by its first line,
by the road to the contagious hospital.
Uh,
this,
uh,
the poem is about the continual
newness that Williams calls life,
something that's continually
constructing the world around us. Uh,
in the poet in this poem gets at it
like the post impressionist painter,
uh, even perhaps like the data is, uh,
by calling his and our attention,
uh,
to the act of constructing his
poem. Uh, and in particularly,
uh,
as that construction is,
is felt as it's kind of brought to
our consciousness through in jam,
uh, Williams, his poetry,
like the world he sees
is constantly in jammed,
segmented, renewed, uh, uh,
by that act.
Uh,
let's look at how in jam works here by
the road to the contagious hospital under
the surge of the blue modeled clouds,
driven from the northeast,
a cold when beyond the waste of broad
money feels brown with dried weeds,
standing and fallen,
patches of standing water,
the scattering of tall
trees all along the road,
the reddish,
purplish forked,
upstanding twiggy stuff of bushes and
small trees with dead Brown leaves under
them.
Leafless vines,
lifeless again,
dead in appearance,
sluggish,
dazed spring approaches.
That is the first verb in the pump.
They,
he now says suggesting
all of these things,
they entered the new world, naked, cold,
uncertain of all save that
they enter all about them.
These things, the things of the
world, the cold, familiar wind.
Now the grass tomorrow,
the stiff curl of wild carrot leaf,
one by one objects are defined
like a series of images.
Poems, it now, not they but it,
which is the again now here a world
felt in its wholeness Quicken's clarity,
outline of leaf,
but now the stark dignity of entrance
still the profound change has come upon
them rooted.
They grip down and begin to awaken.
It's a great pump. Uh, and in jam is
a key part of its energy.
Uh,
the first, uh, in jam at
that is striking a, is bold.
It's one of the really famous ones, in
fact in modern poetry is that second line,
this, uh, under the surge of the blue,
it invites us to read the blue as a noun,
right?
Uh, and to feel and hear that
phrase, the surge of the blue,
uh,
as a kind of a conventional expression
of lyric romantic exaltation.
But we're wrong. Uh, blue is, uh,
an adjective, uh, and, uh, uh,
we learned this as the poem
turns. Uh, and, uh, the, uh,
in Jasmine, uh, supplies the
information that this blue,
this kind of exalted thing,
uh,
is actually modeled a marred war,
flawed even in some sense.
Uh,
uh, and, um, uh, here, um,
the newness that the poem
is going to celebrate, uh,
is going to be something
we might feel modeled, uh,
that, uh, uh, cold, uh, flawed,
which is part of its claim to be new,
uh,
part of its claim to represent
something really real.
Uh, not to be found in
previous books of poetry, uh,
but something, uh, to
be found in living. Uh,
so at this moment it seems in
jam it means disestablishment,
uh, that word of, uh, Williams's
the subversion of life has,
it just was, uh, uh,
a surprise of perception.
But yeah.
Uh, as in the red wheelbarrow, uh,
if you think we've now learned what
[inaudible] means in a given context,
Williams is going to do
something else. Uh, uh,
the next lines are also sharply in Jammed,
um,
uh,
modeled clouds driven from the northeast,
a cold when beyond the waste of broad,
muddy fields.
Uh, I mean, that's a,
that is itself a bold thing to have
done in poetry to break off align at the
definite article. Uh, I'm not sure
that there's an example, uh, in,
uh,
poetry previously to align to this,
these examples of lines ending in
the, okay. Uh, there may well be,
but it's, it's, it's yet a, a
novel and bold thing for, um,
uh, uh, Williams to do, uh,
but it works differently from
the previous example where,
um, uh, the blue invited us to, um,
read that phrase as a kind of Noun,
uh,
expressive of romantic
exaltation and then,
and then gave us the surprise that no,
it doesn't function that way and what
you thought was a pure and exalted as in
fact modeled and, and a messy, uh,
these in jam, it's don't have any kind
of interpretive surprise like that.
The lines are just broken
that way. Uh, they,
they don't change the,
how we read the grammar of the phrases.
They don't force us to
recast our expectations. Uh,
together though as a series
of, and Jim Mintz, uh,
these lines evoke a state in which the
world is freshly taking shape coming at
us and informs, uh, that we have
to confront, uh, that are, uh, uh,
that give us abrupt insistent impressions,
uh,
which are sometimes full of
meaning and sometimes not. Uh,
this is a poetic version
way. Williams is, uh,
is constructing this poem
is a poetic version, uh,
of the action that the poems describing
the going forward into spring against
the cold,
uh,
through which eventually one
by one objects are defined, uh,
defined and organized and energized
and animated as William sees it.
As I say, uh, the verb does
not come in the poem, uh,
until uh, we see, uh, that
phrase spring approaches, uh,
almost a at the middle of, slightly
beyond the middle of the poem. Uh,
and then, uh, that next, um, uh,
sentence they entered the new world naked.
Uh,
they being deliberately vague, uh, uh,
evoking the things of the world,
but in a humanized way, uh,
uh, a humanized way as we come
to feel them and see them,
they enter the world just
as we do naked. Uh, and,
uh, uh, and we, we enter it
naked with them. You could say,
uh, this is a poem about, uh,
emergence a that identifies
a modern poetry modern verse,
uh, as William calls it, uh, uh, Williams
calls it in his letter to Monroe,
uh, identifies modern verse
with the process by which
the perceptual world takes
shape, grips down, grips, down,
routing itself in ordinary fact
and things, uh, and from which, uh,
uh, kind of, uh,
energy is drawn and we begin to awaken.
This is probably a good, uh,
uh, place to, to, and, uh,
I want to stress the resonance and,
and,
and suggestiveness of, of, um, uh,
Williams is investment in what
is naked. It's a, it's a way of,
uh, um, envisioning the
world in its primary terms.
It's also a way of calling forth
a kind of, uh, human energy,
uh, that is, uh, primary,
uh, and, uh, again as, um,
uh, Williams a imagines that, uh, modern.
And here he is a in the buff, um, uh, uh,
I guess,
uh,
skinny dipping in New Jersey with a
couple sticks to pretend he's pan.
Um, so, uh, go enjoy the
spring day. Uh, and we all,
um, uh, keep your clothes on. And, uh,
we'll, um, talk about maybe
a little more Williams,
but definitely Mary and more next time.